[Music]
[Applause]
stars are gigantic balls of fire holding
planets asteroids and meteorites in
their firm gravitational grip
and their fire sends light into the
farthest reaches of their galaxies but
how did they get here
I mean these incredible orbs must have
come from somewhere right
what would it be like to witness this
epic birth
what would it feel like at the center of
the action
and why would this beautiful event have
a funny smell
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you saw a star being born
the Milky Way galaxy spans about 100
000 light years across and it contains
somewhere around 200 billion stars
if there are that many stars in our
little section of space real estate
imagine how many there are in the entire
universe
now depending on where you look in the
night sky you could see around 5 000
Stars just with your naked eye
the brightest ones have melodic names
like Polaris Alpha Centauri and
Beetlejuice
looking further out into the universe
with the help of telescopes there are
simply too many stars to name
that's the North Star
well what is that that's why many of
these are now identified more
generically like wasp 50
hd28678 and hat p23
but today you're not just going to look
into a telescope and name some baby
Stars
you're going to be in the thick of it
the hot dense thick of it
to make this epic journey to a newborn
star you need to raise a lot of money
and not all Investments are a great
choice take the metaverse for example it
took billions of dollars to develop and
sadly if you had the foresight to invest
in companies that could Define Our
Generation like meta was supposed to you
saw your Investments vaporized luckily
there are always new ways to get some
money back like an asset class that's
outpaced the tech heavy standard in
Poor's 500 over the last 26 years I'm
talking about Contemporary Art and now
you don't have to be a billionaire to
invest in your favorite Banksy artwork
thanks to Masterworks Masterworks paid
out tens of millions of dollars in total
to their investors last year and that's
not a one-off every Masterworks exit to
date has returned a profit to investors
like you just take a look at this
performance the results speak for
themselves with 645 000 plus users
Masterworks offerings have sold out in
minutes they even had to make a special
wait list for new users but I've got
special access for you guys to skip it
so click on the link in the description
right now and start investing in minutes
with all this money you might just be
reaching for the Stars
every year seven new stars are born in
the Milky Way alone
now that might not sound like a whole
lot but keep in mind that our galaxy is
already used up 90 of its star making
material over the billions of years of
its existence and yet new stars are
still being born all the time
now to witness their birth you need to
travel to one of the many Star nurseries
in the universe these are known as
nebulas
nebulas are huge clouds of gas and dust
that can span light years across
so hop into your Interstellar spacecraft
and set your coordinates for one of the
most famous Stellar nurseries of our
galaxy I'm here
1344 light years away
the Orion Nebula
yeah it's here that you'd find the
necessary ingredients for a Star to be
born
gas dust gravity and turbulence
sounds like my car
being in the middle of a nebula would
feel like being in the clouds
you'd be surrounded by over 200
different kinds of molecules there would
be hydrogen and helium gas as well as
microscopic grains of silicon and iron
and I hope you packed some warm clothes
because conditions In This Cloud would
be frigid
you'd need a spacesuit thick enough to
withstand temperatures as low as minus
270 degrees Celsius
but don't worry
things are about to heat up
suddenly you'd be hit by a blast this
would be a ripple effect from an
exploding nearby star and it would cause
the nebula to become turbulent
all it means is that the gases around
you would start to mix and swirl
together it would be the beginning of
the Epic event you're here for
first dust particles would begin to
Clump together these clumps would become
denser and denser forming knots
once these knots gain enough Mass they'd
start to collapse under their own
gravity
and their internal pressure and
temperature would increase
yeah at around 2200 degrees Celsius
these high pressure knots would emit a
dull red glow you wouldn't be able to
see it because that light would be
infrared oh but you would be
uncomfortably aware of the temperatures
starting to rise
and things would keep heating up
eventually the Proto star before your
eyes would emit its first rays of
visible light
wait
do you smell that
well no of course you don't you're
wearing a heat resistant spacesuit but
if you could you'd learn that this hot
mass of dust and gas would also smell
it's disgusting but not necessarily in a
bad way depending on the mixture of
compounds around you you could detect
hints of sweetness lemon or even alcohol
but be careful your baby star wouldn't
only be pulling things inward every now
and then it would shoot powerful Jets
from its poles at supersonic speeds
these would flash brightly as they come
into contact with the surrounding gases
all the while the protostar would
simultaneously grow and collapse under
its own weight
this would make the core continue to
heat up
yeah once it reached the scorching hot
temperature of 5 million degrees Celsius
you'd witness your baby star's first
nuclear fusion
deep within the center of the star four
hydrogen atoms would fuse together to
form helium
this would release a ton of energy
and with all that energy the protostar's
pulsations would come to a halt
it would finally become a star
now during the excitement of witnessing
a star being born you'd have seriously
lost track of the time
if the star that formed in front of your
eyes was similar to our sun well you'd
have just watched 50 million years fly
right by you
and you might want to get your hearing
checked After experiencing all this
of course there's no sound in the vacuum
of space we all know that but in the
Stellar Nursery filled with gas and dust
sound waves may have a medium to travel
through
and if you were wondering what the birth
of a star sounds like well it would be
deafening
if we could hear our own son it would be
a lot like Earth was covered and
constantly wailing Sirens except
multiplied by ten thousand
a new star created by a series of
violent contractions of superheated gas
forget about it
okay now that your baby star is all
stabilized it could burn bright for
another 10 billion years
maybe you'd also want to stick around
for an extended vacation to see the end
of its life but that's a story
for another
what if
foreign